it's funny because the simulation
hypothesis for the listeners that may
not know is basically the supposition
that as computing power doubles every
year year and a half according to what's
known as moore's law your computers get
cheaper they get more powerful they get
faster
and um that that extrapolation there's
no natural starting point i mean when
you made the first computer or whatever
that for us is but could it not be that
they get to so much power that they can
simulate every single physical object in
the universe and they can simulate all
and if we're just material objects our
brains are just you know wet computers
but they're just computers they have
neurons that have carbon you know and
dna and so forth but um why couldn't
that be simulated in some in some great
vast computer of the future that doesn't
exist yet but we would be kind of like
you know the sim city right or you know
whatever in the matrix in essence yeah
it would be in the matrix
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
distinguished professor of physics at
the center for astrophysics and space
sciences at uc san diego and author of
the new book into the impossible think
like a nobel prize winner brian keating
finally welcome to the reuben report
thank you dave you were my first big
guest on my podcast so it's it's nice to
return the favor i know you've been
looking forward to having a big guest
like me on for a while
i've wanted a man of science on for
quite some time and no i've wanted to
talk to you for a while on the show
because i think this will be a little
bit different than the shows that that
we normally do but framing one thing
sort of politically just to jump us off
as a man of science and as a man that
just wrote a book about how scientists
approach science what do you make of the
state of science at the moment science
is getting pretty banged up these days
yeah it's it's tough you know i used to
say i enjoy being an astronomer because
there's no republican asteroids there's
no democratic comets uh there's no you
know it's apolitical but it's become
incredibly politicized as you point out
uh i always point out dave you know the
word science in latin i know you're a
scholar so you'll know this word science
means knowledge it doesn't mean wisdom
so to expect wisdom from people that are
knowledge you know junkies wikipedia has
a lot of knowledge doesn't have any
wisdom you wouldn't want to trust your
dog with it right so i i do believe that
we're living in a fundamentally uh
scientific technological age that kind
of is worshiping scientists way more
than i think we weren't uh as anyone
who's ever known uh the famous joke
about scientists how do you know a
scientist is outgoing because he looks
at your shoes when he talks to you
and uh you know it's it's it's part of
the goal of this book is to humanize
scientists and to to you know recognize
that we're just human beings we have no
special you know truth claims or wisdom
claims than anyone else
does that sort of chasm between
knowledge and wisdom sort of capture
exactly the moment we're at in a way
where it's like we hear things every day
in the news okay there's a new study
that says something
that tells us something about knowledge
to some degree but then the wisdom of
the policies that then we are told we
have to follow often seems a little
screwy at least in my humble opinion
yeah looking again you know if you look
to somebody uh for wisdom when you know
again looking for to wikipedia for
wisdom is not going to be too fruitful
uh and yet we crave it because we
worship at the altar of science in some
way justifiably so it's led to life
you know increases uh child mortality
rates plummeting vaccines and so forth
that are just miraculous and in any
other way would be difficult to describe
it understanding the composition
evolution
of the universe you know to to a
fraction of a percent just astonishing
and yet
we don't as a laity as the layp person
don't really have a good understanding
of how science works so as the words of
arthur c clarke say any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic and some say it could be
indistinguishable from a god and so i
think there is a tendency a desire to
worship
at the altar of science and i think
that's misplaced because we don't elect
scientists uh as a population we elect
politicians a president uh governors etc
we elect those people and they want to
pass off i think some of their
responsibility the scientists who we
don't elect and we wouldn't elect in any
other capacity
so last part on this specifically but do
you sense that sort of the reputation
that science and scientists have gotten
over the last year where it's been so
sort of battered and inconsistent and
wear masks don't wear masks it's the vax
is working it's not working booster
shots the whole thing do you think it
can recover in the next couple years
because right now when they just trot
out the next study like at this point
i'm just like this is just just more
nonsense i'm not saying i don't believe
that the study was conducted but what it
will always lead to is just like i can't
listen to this stuff anymore well the
biggest misconception is that science
has ever settled i think the public has
that to their to their you know to their
dismay because believing that science is
settled is antithetical to science think
about it dave if if uh galileo came
along and said well aristotle was a
scientist he's very smart uh i'll just
accept that there are only four elements
instead of you know 114 or that heavy
things fall faster than light things all
these things he could have verified by
the way but he didn't actually go out
and do that uh but galilei would never
have come up with the laws of initial
laws of relativity same with newton
einstein because well newton is a genius
i can't outdo newton as he often looked
up to him so therefore as richard
feynman the great nobel laureate of the
20th century said science is the belief
in the ignorance of experts otherwise
you'd have no motivation to ever modify
refine and improve upon who or what came
before you so i i view that uh and i
view it to the to the detriment of
science and scientists themselves you
know often people say i'm no einstein i
can't understand it well guess what dave
einstein wasn't einstein you know in the
beginning of his life so i think the
more that we kind of venerate without
explaining how science is actually done
it harms our own practitioners of the
craft of science that i i am engaged in
yeah and that really actually is what
the book is about because you talk about
things like creativity and human
expression and passion all of these
things that we don't really associate
with scientists and their work
specifically so let's just dive in so
you have nine chapters here each one
going off a different scientist for a
different reason i thought we could just
spend a couple minutes on everybody but
you got to leave some secrets here
otherwise people won't buy the book so a
couple minutes on everybody i know how
it works chapter one is about adam reese
the stargazer yeah so adam is a
contemporary of mine he's basically my
age and back in uh i think it was 2005
there was a worldwide competition to
determine uh who was the greatest you
know scientist under the age of 40 and
he and i entered it i came in first as
the most promising scientist of all time
at least of that age and then adam came
in third uh and so uh later you know six
years later when he won the nobel prize
my older brother kevin who watches the
show uh he called to report on me and
said brian you won the battle but adam
was a war brother you you
you had the temporary reprieve so adam
is um is an incredibly curious uh
individual he's very young and what is
often said about the nobel prize in fact
by nobel laureate t.s eliot who won it
for literature he said the nobel is a
ticket to your own funeral because no
one ever does it after he wins it and
adam is a real counter example to that
canard because he has gone on to you
know great heights astronomically and
otherwise uh educational mentorship etc
i think he best exemplifies the fact
that you know dave i never thought i
could be a professional astronomer you
know growing up as we did on long island
uh you know i thought like oh someone's
gonna pay me to be an astronomer like
they're gonna pay me to be an ice cream
taster or you know or a wizard or
something like that so i really do look
at him as the fulfillment of this dream
that you can do it uh you can achieve
your your passion but passion alone is
not enough you need to have insatiable
curiosity i say passion is a spark but
the fuel is actually curiosity
i have to tell you that growing up on
long island as you noted uh in 1997 i
think i told you this when i was on your
podcast i ate some pop brownies and then
went to see the movie contact by the
great science communicator carl sagan
and i was basically tripping and i'm
sure you've seen the beginning of that
movie many times that spectacular
panorama of the universe and it blew my
mind and i ended up reading i think i've
read every one of carl sagan's books
since then well wow you know he passed
he had he had passed away i think a few
months before the movie came out yeah
but i had read all of his books um so it
is possible that someone from long
island could stare into the stars and
think something you know i had his wife
his widow andrew and who's the author on
on contact and his daughter on my
podcast sasha sagan and uh he had
something very pertinent to your book
you know don't burn this book he said
books dave are magic they are the
implantation of an author long dead
perhaps although not for you or me
hopefully for many centuries to come uh
and you the wisdom distilled you know
per word the price per word of wisdom in
a book carl you hopefully me uh these
are really invaluable things and i think
of these as hacks and these scholars
that i profile in the book they all make
use of that and credit these great you
know scientists and authors that came
before
let me ask you one other thing about the
people that look into the distance and
are always trying to figure out what's
going on the cosmos and the stars and
everything else you'll hear now oh but
we have so many problems here we
shouldn't be funding any of these things
and we know that a lot of it now a lot
of the exploration is being done
privately obviously elon musk and some
other people what do you make of
that sort of general outlook well i
think that that you know separating out
you know the space program and
exploration of space from pure research
so what i do is called in one of the
chapters by nobel laureate uh sheldon
glacial what i do the origin evolution
of the universe cosmology not to be
confused with cosmetology uh that you
can tell i'm a master practitioner
thereof um
that we do in his words
useless ideas
we basically pursue stuff that has no
net benefit at least so we think now and
here's a good example the discovery of
the of this emanation from the big bang
that i study called the cosmic microwave
background radiation it's an
all-pervasive glow of radio or
microwaves it was discovered completely
serendipitously by two radio astronomers
and of all places new jersey uh homedell
new jersey and uh and they uh couldn't
get rid of it but the way reason that
they were so vital to even the
communication technology that we're
having now they were working at bell
laboratories now bell laboratories
doesn't exist anymore uh at least in
that form and that's much more
detrimental i think a place that was
doing pure research studying astronomy
how could that have any benefit and yet
david who better to mine precious weak
radio signals that would then lead to
cell phone technology
than those that study basic pure aka
useless science like my fellow
astronomers so the point is you can
never really tell where serendipity will
strike and where that will lead to
technology that could scarcely have been
imagined you know even a few decades
earlier
if i can harken back to contact which i
think i'm going to do 20 times in this
interview i mean there's a great debate
at one moment it's just a few minutes
long between uh ellie airway who of
course is jody foster and tom skerritt
who plays the head of the science
foundation we're saying and they're
arguing about public funding versus
whether the you know can we do pure
research that has no sort of
empiricalness value necessarily that we
know about at that moment versus as he
says well the people that are footing
the bill should get something out of
this so that that must be the endless
battle between the bureaucrat the
scientists and the taxpayers yeah you
know some people say the problem with
science is that it often produces
technology so
because it produces technology on
occasion we expect it to always produce
it you know it's like
a great you know a great base runner and
baseball he may or would be a good
sprinter but that's not exactly their
core competency so yes i think you have
to do serendipitous research and this
great society like ours should do
serendipitous or aka useless research
chapter two is uh rainer weiss the
tinkerer
so uh raynor or ray weiss as we as we
know and love them i think he's the
oldest laureate in the book but he's so
energetic uh he was responsible in part
along with barry barish who uh is a good
friend of mine and wrote the uh forward
to the book he um the two of them and
their colleague at cal tech kept thorn
responsible for one of your favorite
movies interstellar i know uh and it's
up there it's up there his uh his uh he
was a physics consultant anyway these
three gentlemen along with a thousand
other people which i want to keep making
the point the science is not done by the
one individual per chapter often times
it's hundreds even thousands in the case
of rainer weiss and in this in this
instance they measured the faint
reverberations of space-time caused by
sun
times a 30. so imagine a black hole 30
times the mass of the sun colliding
together smashing apart and
reverberating time like a like a drum
head oh and by the way it's 1.3 billion
light years away so the signals traveled
for over a billion years to get to us
now he credits some of these techniques
that he used with his colleagues to
detect this most minute
uh fluctuations in the space-time
continuum literally uh to his tinkering
days as a young boy in the 30s and 40s
having just escaped uh germany with his
with his father who i believe is jewish
and he went to you know he was living in
new york and he would go to flea markets
and pick up phonographs and vacuum tubes
and and just tinker around with them and
in so doing he kept not just the passion
again i think passion is necessary but
not sufficient curiosity is the fuel
that will take you on the sustained
journey and that's what's kept him going
and to me dave what he told me the
advice that i take away the most is that
if you're not having fun you're doing it
wrong the dirty little secret and please
don't tell your friend gavin newsom this
uh please i am
my good buddy yeah yeah
i am a state employee he is my boss at
some level right so i'm a university of
california professor proud to be some
i would do what i do for free dave uh it
is so much fun i get to work with the
brightest people not just in california
around the world i get to talk to people
in my outreach uh you know my podcast
etc and i get to play around with
technology paid for by you the taxpayer
and you pay your taxes i i've checked
into that um and so i view that as my
obligation to give back free information
to the public so i view that as my moral
obligation it's not a business i don't
make any money from it but i like ray
ray weiss find this great pleasure in
reinventing what i do every so often in
order to better communicate to the
customer which is the scientific tax
paying public
brian i suddenly feel probably
two percent happier about my california
taxes that you moved me you moved me
about two percent all right arizona can
wait sheldon glashow the nucleator
shelley or sheldon glacier so he's the
namesake inspiration for the big bang uh
theories uh sheldon young sheldon
sheldon um he's a throwback to he's an
older guy and and he
really you know made his way doing
something quite unique my wife told me
last night she was reading it and yeah i
wrote another book before this i'm not
convinced she read that book dave don't
tell her i said so although she's a big
fan of yours so she she'll be
disappointed to know if you read that
first book and not this anyway so she
was reading less she's like this is so
appropriate because what he discovered
like
the discovery that electricity and
magnetism and technical physics terms
are basically two different aspects of
one underlying physical law and that's
called electromagnetism so that you can
turn a small current can move a motor
and spin a motor you could also spin
that motor and generate a current that's
in fact how current and electrical power
generation works um so he discovered the
analog of that unification in what's
called the nuclear force it's not super
important to get into but it really
delineated how these things that we
perceive very different a magnet that
you put on your refrigerator and uh you
know a 9-volt battery they seem very
different but they are different
manifestations of the same underlying
coin he did so with his colleagues uh
stephen weinberg and abdul salam in the
60s and 70s they discovered a similar
feature of uh the nuclear force and my
wife was reading she's like this is so
interesting because what one person
perceives as a manifestation say pure
electricity another will perceive as
magnetism or as one person sees as
electricity we'll see as a nuclear force
that's so interesting because could you
imagine dave as you do often and you
talk about in your book can you argue
the other person's side can you do that
because otherwise as you said i might
like debate is kind of pointless like
you oh joe biden did a great you know
debating with trump i'm going to vote
for him now as a die hard no that never
happened but if you can say i see your
perspective right and literally it is
just as kosher just as good as another
person's perspective well then why not
use that as a metaphor for how we could
be maybe a little less polarized so i
like that she got i wasn't intending to
say that um but but it did come out and
uh from her interpretation of reading
this chapter about how things that
appear so different dave are really the
same manifestation of of the underlying
same phenomenon we actually could use a
little bit more of that in politics i'm
sure i could use a little bit more of it
personally as well uh then there's an
interstitial should we go into the
interstitial why'd you throw an
interstitial into the book
what's going on here
i got paid by the word
it's a short book you know and it's it's
not there's no physics equations there's
no homework uh you know although you you
know you being a master of quantum
electrodynamics would have done quite
well if there were exactly i had uh
custom illustrations and i should say i
have a podcast where i give away all
these interviews you don't have to buy
the hope you will i hope you'll get the
audio or the the printed book but um but
i actually wanted to to really make this
this point clear there is no one way to
do science dave like you asked me in the
beginning about science there is no
science says or follow this there's not
even science like science uh is
essentially
basically a you know a shortcut a hack
for us unraveling fundamental truths
that never is perfect is guaranteed to
be imperfect and so some of us gives
great comfort because you can never get
the right answer in other words newton
was darn smart and he was responsible
for the laws that take elon musk spacex
to the to the stars and took the apollo
astronauts to the surface of the moon um
but if you want to go and understand the
properties of a black hole his work will
not do and you need einstein well guess
what
einstein's not the right answer either
we're going to find some subsequent
improvement to it maybe quantum gravity
which will you know we'll get it we have
a 10-part learning company series you
and i on that so we can refer people to
that lecture series but that's not quite
that's and guess what that won't be the
final answer either so i want to show
that there's different approaches to
arriving at truth you can manifest them
i was talking to tom bilya who lives in
l.a is a famous podcaster great guy i
had him on the show i was actually at
his laboratory and he told me his way
that he works through you know when he
was at quest nutrition and he was
developing these really tasty but
nutritious bars protein bars whatever
and the scientific method that he was
using
and how he also applies it to venture
capital or to now he's into nfts and
bitcoin and stuff like that but it's a
it's a process of thinking guaranteed to
be imperfect but better than all the
rest so i want to outline how you can do
it my avatar is a is a car salesman in
tulsa oklahoma
it's not a scientist it's not written
for science science majors and that you
can apply methodological thinking
testing hypotheses listening to your
critics
achieving consensus and realizing in
surreptitiously perhaps that when you
hear things like 99 of scientists agree
you should be very concerned
we should be very we hear an awful lot
about that these days uh on many fronts
actually not just covid climate change
all sorts of things uh carl wyman the
teacher's teacher
yeah so for a long time i had been kind
of an acolyte of malcolm gladwell uh who
you know popularized he didn't invent
this this uh this this concept but the
so-called ten thousand hour rule so i
did a little math you've been doing
podcasting uh the reuben report they've
been on you know 2000s early 2000s
you've had way more than 10 000 hours
but the study that gladwell and uh and
anders ericsson popularized was that
basically the best pilots have 10 000
hours of flight experience bill gates
had like 10 thousand hours of computer
programming by the time microsoft steve
jobs had ten thousand yeah so he done
it's basically it's not a scientific
analysis it's really correlative um and
i wanted to know well we as professors
we
never really get taught how to teach
it's very rare you may be interested in
teaching and pedagogy but we have so
many other obligations in addition to
teaching research funding
bureaucracy you know and getting through
you know all the different hoops of
working not just at a state university
any university
and then teaching is on there and it's a
big priority it's the reason we get into
it but oftentimes we're
distracted by other quotidian demands
and in this case i wanted to kind of
demystify how should we be teaching
because i don't know if you know it but
the way that we teach with like some
dude scraping a piece of rock on another
piece of rock that is almost exactly a
thousand-year-old model it's not been
disrupted since the year 1080 in bologna
italy when the first modern university
incarnation came along where you'd have
some guy you know and but the only thing
that's better now is that back then dave
the students could go on strike and the
professors would not get paid so thank
god we have tenure i mean that you know
that's barbaric that is a barbaric
practice but other than that what has
changed so i got into all sorts of
things could we have an artificial
intelligent professor could we alleviate
some of the the burden but also free up
the the minds and the time of the
student to do it and he likened our
current practice of teaching to the
medical practices of the 18 and 17th
century with leeches and bloodletting he
said we're at a primitive state and we
need to go beyond that he has some
models to do it i don't think any of
them are foolproof but the key takeaway
i took dave is that
to be a good teacher you have to be a
student of teaching
and i pointed out in the book that the
word scientist in the russian language
means someone who was taught to me that
conveys an obligation you both have to
be a good student but you have to be a
good teacher to pay it forward to the
next generation and so i think he
exemplifies that to me and really made
me want to double down and be a better
teacher
by studying teaching and that's not
something i really have that much time
to do but i find a little bit of effort
goes a long way with it and i hope in
anybody's field the way to learn
something to be a better salesman to be
a better podcaster i think i asked you
when you came i was like how do you know
dave when you're giving a good interview
when you're doing a good job as an
intern like there's no like you don't
have a grader anymore but you must study
it and you must listen to it and even if
that means studying with people that
maybe you don't agree with all the time
you can learn a lot and that's part of
the humble
you know nature that i think it takes to
be a good student and ergo a good
teacher it's interesting because as
you're talking about that i'm thinking
of like all of the videos that we see on
twitter every day where a student will
take a video of a teacher just doing
everything wrong either the way they're
trying to brainwash them or yell at them
and whatever and it's just like man
there is so much broken in our education
system all together but that's for a
different show
roger penrose the singular mind
ah yeah so roger just celebrated his
90th birthday and he made appearance in
a theory of everything the movie uh with
eddie redmayne i guess um and that was
about stephen hawking who is his you
know famous late great friend and
collaborator and colleague uh at
cambridge uh well roger was at oxford so
roger came up with really whimsical
almost whimsical drawings and cartoons
and schematics that demonstrate what
would happen to your watch dave as you
get close to a black hole what would
happen as you go beyond what's called
the event horizon
how would things proceed how would your
future look how would you look to
someone on the outside world and he did
this very intuitively through a series
of cartoons almost and it's in his
tradition as an artist he's really a
mathematician and he's invented these
wonderful things that are evocative of
escher you know drawings with you know
staircases that just seem to keep going
up or these fishes that tile this whole
sphere and so forth and he thinks
geometrically he thinks artistically his
dad was an artist and many of these uh
men unfortunately i tried to get the two
living nobel prize laureates in physics
that are female um they both rejected me
so that took me back to high school
getting rejected by brilliant women
um but uh but you know for various
reasons they weren't able to do it but
i'm hoping hope springs eternal and i'll
keep going i hope there's more female
laureates obviously i have daughters
myself and then maybe someday they could
be among them but
the um the point being uh when i asked
them like who are the most common thing
i got was a father or you know our
teacher and i took that very seriously
again that you um can be a father to
even if you don't have biological
children these men are ideological
fathers in some sense to millions of
people around the world uh and yet they
they haven't written their biography i
mean none of them have a biography uh
which is kind of interesting so i wanted
to do that as a service such that maybe
someone could be influenced by them the
way that they've influenced me through
their technical writing but you might
not know that actually they're really
good with dealing with like you know ven
vengeful competitors and things like
that that is actually what we deal with
day to day isn't it it's not it's not
like stroking my non-existent beard you
know thinking about contemplating the
cosmos i get to do that on occasion but
not that often mostly it's dealing with
troublesome you know suppliers and
vendors and getting equipment to the
site and the students having a problem
and
that's you know i want to go beyond that
and i think having mentors and avuncular
figures like i do in the book i think
i'm hoping that that will influence
people to see the human side of science
right and also of course doing some of
this through art and technology can
awaken people in a way that just the guy
at the chalkboard can't do how did
interstellar do in that regard when they
were going over that event horizon right
because they had to drop the uh the
robot i forget what he was called tars
had to be dropped in there's a lot of
imagery there about light can't escape
from the other side and all of that yeah
how they do how they do so that was all
influenced by sir roger penrose who
influenced kip thorne who is another
laureate that i hope to get on the show
who is responsible for winning the the
nobel prize along with colleagues for
the ligo experiment ray weiss we already
talked about and um so a lot of you can
take a lot of what i call physicist
license
because these things are not
approachable it's not like i was talking
on a podcast earlier this week um with a
biology professor and she was talking
about you know and i was like don't
don't talk to me about that because um
you know i'm so bad at biology that when
i dissected a frog in high school the
frog lived you know it was i just
couldn't do it but in astronomy so in
other words you can't do an experiment i
can't say hmm dave what if uh the cosmos
had twice as much dark matter oh let me
just you know i'm god and no no you
can't do that whereas you can have a
control uh you know and a variable and
do stuff in biology so astronomy and in
particular cosmology is very hard but
what you can do is take a lot of
artistic license the fact that you can't
go near a black hole you can't go back
to the big bang means that you can do a
lot with simulations that uh really let
the imagination run wild
i think that was your way of saying that
the interstellar scene was pretty cool
as well
yeah you know what happened the first i
never saw i was going to the i had to go
to the mexican border to get like a
global entry card a few years back i
hadn't seen interstellar and um the guy
in front of me was a professor also
at scripps institution of oceanography
and i was like holy crap they're going
to think like it's a conspiracy like all
these professors are coming to the
border to get their passport either get
there or whatever and the guy said to me
first i heard him ask some the guy in
front of me some questions then he said
to me like um well you know oh you're an
astrophysicist you think you're smarter
than me like you got a pretty big gun
over there i better be careful and i
said well you know i hadn't seen it dave
so i had to like think fast on my feet
and i said well um you know interstellar
you know he asked me what do you think
about interstellar you're so smart well
the gravitational space time continuum
can be warped by four dimensional but
not in a manifestation and i just bs my
way out of it but luckily i only spent
three nights in the tijuana prison
i've been doing that my whole life with
star wars so you're good to go
uh duncan haldane the alchemist
yeah so this is a guy who along with
colleagues invented a theoretical type
of matter
a phase of matter not known to exist and
purely intellectually
and it was it's so weird dave it's
actually we exist in three dimensions we
can go up down backwards forwards left
right
um but he envisioned a two-dimensional
world
very different with time proceeding but
also but confined to two dimensions like
an ant would feel you know bulbous and
and and and curvy right but but a flat
surface and then he asked well what
would matter behave like then
and uh he speculated and he came up with
this new type of matter and uh and it
would have certain properties and it
would behave in an interesting way but
everyone thought it was purely
mathematical until experimental
physicists devised ways to actually
simulate a two-dimensional world um by
you know basically printing on on with
very special media
types of exotic phenom and then they
found that these objects behave
differently in two dimensions in three
dimensions so he really
conceived in his mind of a new element
of a new type of matter and i found that
very interesting and so i call him the
alchemist yes it is a very clever
alchemist of course were people that
thought they could turn um ordinary base
metals into gold and actually some of
the greatest minds in history like isaac
newton did that and that's actually part
of what you said in the very beginning
because actually the hard sciences they
have pretty shaky you know past history
so chemistry evolved from uh from
essentially from alchemy astronomy
evolved from astrology um
and uh and and obviously medicine
evolved from you know leeches and
bloodletting like we talked about
earlier so you know i think we have a
tendency to want to kind of glorify you
know all the scientific method and there
is no scientific method that's that's
you know full stop there are ways to
methodologically approach scientific or
knowledge based questions and i think
this way of like coming up with a new
form of matter purely in the human brain
i think that's just so fascinating how
long did it take before he met the guy
that was able to actually replicate it
in the real world years years and it's
funny because in the interview at the
end he starts talking about well i don't
think this is going to make a new iphone
like it's not going to improve your life
but i was like the history of science
tells us otherwise like there's a very
good chance that you know like if you
ask these guys who discovered this hiss
of microwaves back in the 60s would we
you know be able to watch you know i
always say my grandmother dave uh you
know she grew up in the shethels and you
know seeing uh horse and buggies and and
she grew up to see
human beings men walking on the surface
of tick tock and you know how wonderful
is that so i'm like telling this guy
holding don't you know uh don't
underestimate what the human mind can do
with uh with with enough time
frank wilson a beautiful mind
yes frank wilcheck uh he is a professor
at mit
now and when he was in his early 20s
dave he came up with an idea so
brilliant along with his colleagues that
it was guaranteed to win a nobel prize
in 1974
he was told he's the wonder kid can of
science he is going to guarantee to make
a trip to stockholm there's just one
catch there's about 20 other guys in
front of you that that
have to get their nobel prizes almost in
order for you to have the validation and
the verification that is necessary in
the scientific method to get consensus
around this physics idea now dave i
imagine you know if if i told you you're
gonna win the lottery uh next week next
year be pretty happy um you know if i
told you you're gonna win in 30 years
what would go through your mind i mean i
think that i'd be thinking about hmm i
got to stay alive you know i got to cut
back on the burgers uh you know but but
imagine that terror and and the pressure
and and so many of them i think you know
they there was such a long delay between
the the work that won them the prize
eventually and the actual awarding of
the prize on december 10th every year in
stockholm sweden and and i think that
that is a lesson in resiliency and
perseverance because he also didn't rest
on that like i might just say okay cool
call you know put me in the coma you
know put on the the feeding tube this
woody allen and sleeper outfit and wake
me up when a stockholm but no he didn't
he went on to invent or create many many
new things and he's an inspiration uh in
many ways for that uh from that he's
also a great writer he writes for the
wall street journal
science column for the wall street
journal which is you know it's not
technical at all and it's it's just
incred he's an incredible intellect
speaking of woody allen and sleeper do
we still not have the cryo sleep things
i mean they were an interstellar too
they're in all the alien movies do those
things exist where are we at with those
things
i don't know every time i go down to my
biology lab uh colleagues they're always
asleep or you know dissecting frogs and
if you had access to those many
chemicals and drugs dave what would you
be doing put yourself in a bag in some
hot water usually and then they get you
it was in the martian too with uh one of
those brownies that you still have left
over from 1997. exactly i wish i had
those john mather the collaborator
yeah john is an incredible guy who also
was kind of a wunderkind and and did a a
tremendous amount of work he is the
stereotypical although he's not a
professor he's a stereotypical you know
professor just super uh super smart can
answer knows everything about about you
know the the field and has contributed
to many many great uh great discoveries
and is about to be
the chief you know scientist behind this
new space telescope that's going to be
launched in december hopefully after a
20-year delay it's one of the most
expensive projects nasa's ever done and
it's a successor to the hubble space
telescope which has revealed more
wonders and mysteries of the cosmos than
any other project um and so he uh he
discovered not serendipitously so he's
an example of a different type of
scientific discovery which is that you
make an extremely precise measurement of
a known quantity something that we knew
existed this microwave background
radiation that i study comes in all
directions originally discovered in new
jersey and uh but he made the most
exquisite measurement ever that put the
nail in the coffin
of any other alternatives that could
plausibly be said to be responsible for
the
appearance of our universe namely there
are people that believed up until then
in the uh early 90s that the universe
could have existed forever in what's
called a steady state and the
measurements that he did for technical
reasons really destroyed all hope for
those who believed in an alternative to
what we now call the big bang
initiation of the universe so he is uh
you know this really quintessential
workmen like studious bookish very very
bright
very very diligent he just keeps going
and again these guys could all retire
and be you know super famous and do
whatever they want to do uh and yet he's
working super hard on this on this next
great space telescope the the dividends
of which may not come for decades or
more how does it go for a guy like that
when he sort of puts that final nail as
you put it and and it sort of blows up
what many in his field think about
something i i suspect there's probably a
lot of resentment there's probably a lot
of denial but slowly kind of people come
along usually
yeah well that's what's so interesting
in that chapter he talks about the
importance of listening to your critics
but not too much
and i kind of summarize this as a trait
um you know in in my students i say you
have to be humble you have to nobody
like someone who's not humble and we'll
talk about you know imposter syndrome
and stuff in a little bit i'm sure but
you need humility but you need swagger
too you need the swagger to know that
you're doing a good job that you are
competent you can't just go i'm timid
i'm humble yeah i can't do anything um
and in his case there were these really
vociferous calls that you know that the
big bang is wrong and it's actually just
a product of you know of of religious
scientists if you can believe such a
thing
and and uh this this impulse that human
beings have to believe in genesis 1 1
etc etc and in the end he said you can
listen to those people you can respect
their scientific contributions
but you shouldn't listen so much that
you
really undermine your own confidence so
it's listening to your critics not
necessarily letting their comments go to
your to your heart
but um but but maybe ingesting them into
your mind processing them analytically
and saying is there a way and i
translated this and we talked about this
before you know steel can you steel man
your critic and can you build up his or
her counter argument to your pet theory
or pet experiment and if you can't it's
not a guarantee that you're wrong you
may be right and they may be just a
blundering idiot who just believes in
some stupid model
but in the case where you can actually
reproduce their arguments it makes your
case that much more strong and i think
that's a trait i want to imbue and you
know other people to to take to heart no
matter what their field and i think he
exemplifies that i suspect that goes far
better in the laboratories that you
people work in rather than the
twitterscape i'm pretty well yeah pretty
sure i don't need to run an experiment
on that my life has been a living
experiment of that
we've got one more and then if you don't
mind i'm gonna throw in my own scientist
i have not planned anything in advance
with you but i'm gonna throw in someone
that has influenced me tremendously
but the last one number nine barry
barish
uh the evuncular avatar
yeah so barry kind of represents the
physicist that i want to be in that and
that the avatar aspect of that and
avuncular because he is just such a warm
gracious individual
so barry really in some ways is
responsible for this book's existence
because it was during the recording of
this episode with him on my podcast into
the impossible uh that he said something
that was kind of interesting and
provocative to me and then i went
further learning the rubinic skills that
i've learned from you um and i went
deeper and what are you talking about he
said to me dave and it blew me away i
said when you were young were you like
this stereotypical brilliant kid in math
and he's like no i was never you know i
was good i was hard work i was smart but
you know he grew up in oklahoma and uh
and then later moved to la and and so
forth and then he was just like
persistent he always wanted to do a
certain type of work called particle
physics and um you know but he was never
under this impression that he was you
know great and i said did you ever have
the imposter syndrome you know when you
were at uc berkeley working for these
famous nobel laureate you know physicist
did you ever feel like you weren't good
enough he goes what do you mean did i
i still feel the imposter syndrome i was
like what are you talking about he said
i feel it worse than ever
and i said you got to explain what are
you talking about he said when you win
the nobel prize
you go to stockholm you meet the king
you bend down and he puts this golden
gilded engraved image of alfred nobel on
your neck and you get a check for some
fraction or a 100 of a million dollar
payout and and you get this portrait
this really beautiful porch i tried to
reproduce the portraits with a really
nice work of an artist in this book i
think he did a wonderful job and um and
and and then you have to sign this
ledger that says yes i receive my nobel
prize and all the accoutrements and
delicacies they're in
and uh and he said when i did that i'm a
very curious person i couldn't resist
who signed it before me so he turned
back the pages he saw richard feynman
marie curie
and he saw albert einstein and he said
dave and the hair still stands up and
said i'm not worthy
i am not einstein i am not good enough
to be there and it made it me feel
completely inadequate completely un up
to the tat not up to the task
and now i'm in the same league as
einstein i do not deserve it
and i said thinking quickly i said barry
guess what
you know who also had the imposter
syndrome albert einstein because albert
einstein was in awe
and wholly inadequate before
isaac newton
and he felt isaac newton dave can you
imagine if einstein were tweeting today
he said the following said isaac newton
revolutionized not only science but
western culture western civilization he
canceled immediately he said newton
had more influence on civilization not
just science than any human before or
since meaning including albert einstein
who was writing this about newton and i
said but wait barry it doesn't stop
there
isaac newton had the severe case of the
imposter syndrome he said what do you
mean i said he felt completely
inadequate before his idol not a
scientist but uh jesus christ in fact
newton said his highest accomplishment
in life is that he died a virgin like
jesus christ he wanted to emulate christ
in every way so i think it's very
fascinating and guess what you know i
don't know maybe jesus didn't have
enough
maybe jesus didn't feel the imposters in
but he was pretty humble and i think he
was a pretty brilliant human being so um
or god depending on on your perspective
right so
uh i think we all can learn this lesson
because if you think that you're the
greatest person and you have these great
contributions and you have like i won
the nobel prize like there are guys i'm
not going to say who but there are
people in the book who said i don't have
the imposter syndrome i deserve this
freaking thing you know like flavor flav
with a huge medallion around this thing
um but they they feel like they deserve
but not all of them
and i think that it's it was a dichotomy
that i wasn't suspecting it was a
dichotomy that you need to have
like i said humility and swagger
but um but you need to be very careful
about it because the imposter syndrome
is born out of insecurity
and people that are arrogant and and
unpleasant they're also insecure right
the old joke and you know this from your
dog
you know the smallest dog barks the
loudest right that's that's the thing
right you talk to jocko on your podcast
jacob's not like oh i'm gonna kick you
you know he's just like whatever man
like i'll run away like i'll put on my
my running shoes and get out of there so
i think that's really interesting
because it's very rare that the opposite
two different traits in diametric
opposition come from the same source
insecurity is responsible for imposter
syndrome and for the uh for the
arrogance that many non-humble people
feel so i felt it was important to
distill this and who better to learn it
from than someone who's achieved and
gotten into the promised land
of my field is the nobel prize there's
no higher thing in all of science maybe
even all of culture civilization and
society than the nobel prize and so i
felt these people in particular barry
and i was so honored that he wrote the
forward to the book um uh as well that
was really a great honor that i do not
feel worthy of
brian that was a beautiful ending to the
interview in a normal situation but i
feel that i must ask you about one other
scientist who is hugely influential i
believe at queen's college and i think
maybe he was a nuclear scientist
dr otto octavius do you do you know of
him he is
no i do not know of him personally is he
a nobel caliber scientist doc ock from
spiderman
octopus he was doing something with
nuclear power with the arms and then he
got them fused to his back and then the
little inhibitor chip blew up next thing
you know
he's working with mysterio and the rest
of the guys
spider-man was very prescient because he
also presaged the existence of the
multiverse in the spider verse right
and now we're all entering the
multiverse that's that's the new thing
you know there's this rumor going around
now that facebook's actually going to
rename itself the multiverse or
something have you heard about this
no i have not heard about that yeah no
that that makes me want to take a
sabbath from uh from all social media
networks but uh except to subscribe to
your feed i i i've thoroughly enjoyed
this i actually have one more for you
which is
are we living in a simulation
ah you know this is the first how's that
for a final question
well usually dave people prefaces i have
a simple question you know like um like
how do you reconcile you know believing
in god with the existence of the big
bang or you know uh now that would be a
simple question the simulation so what's
so interesting about the simulation is
that it actually has a lot of bases in
both classical philosophy you know kind
of the pascals wager kind of the um uh
the decardian cogito ergo sum i think
therefore i am people don't realize that
that was predicated so so descartes said
how do i know i'm not just a brain in a
vat basically that was their simulation
of the time
and he said i i know i am not because i
think therefore i am but there was a
predicate sentence which was that god
created him so in other words actually
descartes can't answer that question
without god and it's funny because the
simulation hypothesis for the listeners
that may not know is basically the
supposition that as computing power
doubles every year year and a half
according to what's known as moore's law
your computers get cheaper they get more
powerful they get faster
and um that that extrapolation there's
no natural starting point i mean when
you made the first computer or whatever
that for us is but could it not be that
they get to so much power that they can
simulate every single physical object in
the universe and they can simulate all
and if we're just material objects our
brains are just you know wet computers
but they're just computers they have
neurons that have carbon you know and
dna and so forth but um why couldn't
that be simulated in some in some great
vast supercomputer of the future that
doesn't exist yet but we would be kind
of like you know the sim city right or
you know whatever in the matrix in
essence yeah would be in the matrix so
there are a lot there are a lot of ways
to actually test for that um and
actually probe for it there's no
evidence that we are in the simulation
that we do live in a matrix
for one question it could have this
infinite regress of possibility so you
could say to me we are simulation i can
say well that's whoever made that
simulation their simulation and whoever
made that simulation and so you would
have to have an infinite not just a
large amount of computing you need an
infinite amount of computing power and
there would be certain glitches and you
know the first thing i would want to
know is why are there so many damn
kardashians like why do we need
so many kardashians in this simulation
but i think it stems from you know both
extrapolating um the the computing power
which actually isn't growing in terms of
like the number of transistors that's
growing but because the computers get
better and better more people want to
use them dave and actually they start to
slow down because their demands are so
much higher they're victims of their own
success and there's no reason to think
that won't happen either with quantum
computers or whatever and the last thing
i i want to say is that
imagine if there is a simulation um and
and there is some simulator and let's
say it's not infinite there's just one
um what ethical you know
responsibilities does that simulation
have
and uh you know to the things that it's
simulating because we feel pain um you
know you could imagine we can create
artificial intelligence ai and that
could feel pain you could make it so
that if it does something you don't like
you unplug it or you pop a transistor or
you you know nail a capacitor in the
middle of the of the circuit board and
it could feel pain uh but can it feel
the kinds of of inspiration the kinds of
you know the ghost in the machine we
don't know yet if that's possible i
happen to be a pessimist i don't think
that artificial intelligence will take
over the the universe or even create new
physics or new art or things like that
um that's categorically different from
what we're seeing now in other words i
like to say humans can be beaten by
computers at chess but can a computer
invent a game of chess i don't think so
brian you are an excellent science
communicator i've thoroughly enjoyed
this it was a little a little different
from our day-to-day political lunacy but
i suspect my audience will enjoy it as
well we're going to link to the book
right down below and uh i've enjoyed
this but for the record not a huge fan
of your boss gavin newsom just in case
anyone was unclear on their feelings on
that well we'll see if you get tenure
after that
thanks brian i'll put in a good word but
we'll see
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell